Good Morning Hank, It's Wednesday.
I'm at my in-law's house.
Like most of the internet,
I am fascinated by honey badgers,
these two to three foot long creatures that
weigh 30 pounds,
live here,
eat....
𝐚𝐧𝐲𝐭𝐡𝐢𝐧𝐠
and lead these solitary, non-monogamous lives of total badassery.
But Hank, Randall's famous and crazy-ass narration
does nothing to capture the glory of the honey badger!
DUN DUN DUN DUN! HONEY BADGER!
Hank, I'm not making this up, although it is hotly debated among naturalists,
but there are lots of reports of honey badgers, which are small,
attacking larger prey
like wildebeest, or zebras, or water buffalo
by going straight for the nuts!
This is known as "emasculating your prey",
basically, you just bite off the balls, and then you attack....
the rest.
Also, there are reports that when honey badgers attack humans,
which does happen occasionally,
they do go straight for the nuts.
DUN DUN DUN DUN! HONEY BADGER!
Hank, a lot of biologists believe that honey badgers are able to attack beehives
because they go up to those beehives and release scent out of their anal glands,
which is so malodorous, that the bees run away
and then the honey badgers are able to take the honey.
That's right, Hank!
They use a fart attack!
So not only do honey badgers have,
like, the most fearsome claws and teeth in the animal kingdom,
they also have the stinkiest farts!
Of course, some bees heroically stay behind and sting honey badgers,
but it doesn't bother them much
because they are more immune to bee venom
than almost any mammal on the planet!
DUN DUN DUN DUN! HONEY BADGER!
So Hank, do you know what cheetah cubs look like?
probably not,
because you probably didn't spend your entire Thanksgiving vacation
researching honey badgers...
they look like this.
And many wildlife biologists speculate this is an evolutionary adaptation
to make baby cheetahs look like honey badgers
because no predator would 𝐞𝐯𝐞𝐫 want to attack a honey badger
unless it is absolutely desperate,
because honey badgers are harder to kill than 19th century Russian monks!
What, it's a Rasputin joke....
It's too obscure‽
C'mon!
Everybody knows Rasputin!
DUN DUN DUN DUN! HONEY BADGER!
Let's tackle the question of why honey badgers are so hard to kill,
so honey badgers, like an Olsen twin,
have more skin than seems entirely necessary
given their frame.
This loose skin-ness means that whenever you grab or bite them,
there's always room for them to, like,
come around and bite you back.
Plus their skin is incredibly thick,
like you can't hack through it with a machete,
and it's resistant to arrows!
It's like some kind of super-skin!
So here you are trying to bite through this super-skin creature,
and he's coming around and biting at your face,
and you're thinking, "Agh! I shoulda gotten a gazelle!"
DUN DUN DUN DUN! HONEY BADGER!
So all this means that the number one honey badger predator,
like most animals,
is humans!
Now honey badger skin is, and I'm not making this up,
can stop some bullets,
but you can kill them with a high-powered rifle.
But they get us back because they often dig up human graves
and eat our ancestors!
DUN DUN DUN DUN! HONEY BADGER!
Honey badgers: Hank, they are not kidding around!
So that's what I did with my Thanksgiving vacation,
I also watched a lot of tape of myself playing FIFA to prepare for the FA cup final.
We're going back--to the FA Cup final!
The Swindon Town Swoodilpoopers will be facing Chelsea football club
and we will avenge our terrible loss in last year's FA cup final
and I am excited!!!
If you don't know what I'm talking about, link in the dooblydoo,
Hank, I hope you learned something about honey badgers,
I will see you on Friday.